uh anthony so you were missed during our
hamilton show this summer i know you got
sick i was so sad
but what was the oddest request um that
you've gotten from a hamilton fan i
didn't get to ask you
i think it was just uh this one this one
girl she was like
she came to so many shows and finally
she stopped me at the stage door and
she's like hey man can you sign my
forehead
and i looked around too and people were
like yo don't sign her forehead but
she's like looking at me like yo my man
please sign my forehead and i was like i
gotta sign
for it man like i can't do her like this
like so you know
what why i mean i've had people ask me
to sign
like their bot and i always say don't do
this those are literally that's what i
say every time
and then they'll get it tattooed and i
think that's a really poor decision
everyone out there but but like wow i
wonder why on the forehead that's just
kind of a weird
but you know what to each his own i
guess um
does she have a five head because i have
a big forehead was it a big forehead
like mine
nothing about her is anything but
remarkable she's gorgeous
you